so what do you do sandy
well i sing
of course
as you dance
care for a demonstration
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
denis villanuev's highly anticipated
adaptation of frank herbert's dune
finally hit theaters part one of the
sci-fi epic grossed 40 million dollars
its opening weekend at the domestic box
office which makes it the highest
grossing debut for the director of
arrival and blade runner 2049 the film
has already grossed over 200 million
dollars worldwide and legendary just
announced that dune part 2 will be
arriving exclusively in theaters on
october 20th 2023 after its
record-breaking debut the previous
weekend halloween kills came in second
with 14 million dollars in the u.s with
a total of 73 million dollars at the
domestic box office the horror sequel is
now the highest grossing r-rated film
since bad boys for life which opened
back in january of 2020. but dune wasn't
the only timote chalamet released last
weekend in limited release wes
anderson's the french dispatch set a
2021 record for per screen average
pulling in an average of 25 000 on each
of the 52 screens it was played on
making it a 1.3 million debut in 14
cities the latest hyper-stylized film
from the director of the grand budapest
hotel will expand to more cities in the
coming weeks be sure to check fandango
to see if these whimsical french vistas
are coming to your town all right now to
some more recent movie news
as reviews begin to pour in for marvel's
next big superhero film eternals doing
theaters november 5th disney has
announced several changes to its release
schedule a bunch of marvel movies and
the next indiana jones sequel have
shifted back due to production changes
among the new release dates doctor
strange into the multiverse of madness
will now open in may of 2022 while black
panther wakanda forever will now open in
november of next year but don't worry
spider-man fans this december's
spider-man no way home is staying put
with director john watts recently
comparing the next spider-man adventure
to the last avengers movie referring to
it as spider-man end game which upcoming
movie are you most excited about
emily blunt is in talks to star in
christopher nolan's upcoming film
oppenheimer the casting would reunite
blunt with her a quiet place part 2
co-star killian murphy who will play the
lead role of physicist j robert
oppenheimer who is also known as one of
the principal creators of the atomic
bomb blunt is expected to play the wife
of oppenheimer the american physicist
who is pivotal in the manhattan project
and rachel vice is set to star in the
adaptation of seance on a wet afternoon
legendary's adaptation of the acclaimed
suspense novel will be directed by
thomas alfredson the horror thriller
follows a self-proclaimed psychic medium
who convinces her husband to kidnap a
child so she can help the police solve
the crime and achieve praise for her
abilities when her true intentions come
to light however her husband realizes
the plan threatens to consume them both
now available to watch in theaters on
friday is last night in soho and antlers
in acclaimed director edgar wright's
psychological thriller eloise an
inspiring fashion designer is
mysteriously able to enter the 1960s
where she encounters a dazzling wannabe
singer sandy but glamour is not all it
appears to be and the dreams of the past
start to crack and splinter into
something far darker
thomas and mackenzie and anya taylor joy
starr writes homage to the giallo a
1960s 70s italian slasher genre which
emphasized bright colors and mystery
novel tropes
[Music]
also available to watch at home is
malignant
when i was young
something happened to me
stop saying that daddy
who are you talking to
gabriel
is he your imaginary friend
whatever you went through before you
joined our family it hurts you in a way
that i can't even imagine
malignant is the latest creation from
the conjuring universe architect james
wan made in between two aquaman films
the movie marks director wands returned
to his roots as a new original horror
thriller in the film madison is
paralyzed by shocking visions of grisly
murders and her torment worsens as she
discovers that these waking dreams are
in fact terrifying realities
rotten tomatoes notes that malignant is
one of 30 certified fresh horror films
released so far in 2021 and if you like
many are running a horror movie marathon
this week voodoo's got you covered there
are
1127 horror films and television shows
in voodoo's halloween horror store
from fan favorites to documentaries
franchise and television bundles
international horror and even 100 free
scary movies be sure to check out the
link below
alright well that's it for today but
before you go leave us a comment and let
us know what you're watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you